the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license
your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to offer high
quality educational resources for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
my name is James Russ I work with
Sudarshan adventure on this project and
what we did is we took a numerical
simulation electrochemical simulation of
a battery and ported it to the
PlayStation 3 so the objective of this
project for this situation was to port a
electrochemical battery simulation to
the PlayStation 3 and I try to take
advantage of the unique features of the
Cell processor to help speed up the
computation of the simulation so when we
talk today we're gonna talk about why we
want to do that we discuss the model we
discuss how we solve it numerically look
at some of our performance results and
then discuss what we wish we could have
implemented ok so the justification is
basically the world needs energy and oil
has been in the news a lot and hasn't
been as a reliable source of energy as
we'd like so in the automotive industry
hybrids seem to be part of the solution
to the energy needs now one of the
problems with hybrids is how much energy
is in your battery so the more
sophisticated battery model that we can
put in a hybrid the better that we're
gonna be off so the more sophisticated
model requires more computation so
you're looking at having a large
superscalar processor in your car or you
could get see if you could get a lot of
small processors to do the same amount
of work and the cell represents the kind
of the first opportunity to be able to
test that hope so
the simulation that we ran Mayson
consisted of a lead-acid battery a cell
so unfortunately they use the word cell
and we're also using the word cell so
it's sort of like the modern-day Smurfs
but so in a lettuce and battery cell you
have a lead dioxide electrode
consists of a number of parts a LED
electrode which also consists of a
number of parts and an electrolyte which
is five molar sulfuric acid which
consists of h2so4 okay when you
discharge the battery you're going to
close the circuit and basically what
ends up happening is you have electrons
flowing on the outer loop and the previa
you're going to have an ionic current so
you have a complete circuit around your
loop and this is the effect that the
simulation is trying to simulate the
simulation works on a very low physical
level and it stimulates the chemical
reactions which empty Linde acts at
electrode it converts lead dioxide into
lead sulfate during discharge reverses
it during charge during discharge the
lead electrode turns light into lead
sulfate and during recharge it converts
that back to implement the model we took
basically and discretize the system and
just kind of cross-section it okay it
took small sections of cross-section
that we're gonna spit this way but
basically to simulate the physics we
have a bunch of nasty nonlinear coupled
partial differential equations this is
an example of two of them and there a
number of other ones that are included
in the system but not really worth just
kind of a feel you get you see a
diffusion term you see in the lower
equation you see a diffusion term you
see a reaction term and the upper
equation you see changing of the
porosity changing the geometry of the
system this is kind of the output that
you could get from this type of battery
simulation and what you're looking at
here is you're looking at if me left
hand side is the electrodes is the top
of the battery and the height of the
battery goes along that way
you see that as you discharge the
concentration at the top of the
electrodes as much the acid is used
consumed where you're drawing current
out most readily so there's a gray the
simulation kind
makes sense even if my speech didn't the
battery model that we use is a two
dimensional model it has both a lead
dioxide and a lagged electrode and an
electrolyte area this is an example of
just the lead dioxide electrode and if
we discretize that in two dimensions we
would get a discrimination that looks
like that if we were to use a single
centered finite volume method but it
turns out that we have so many
discontinuities in here that it's much
better to use a staggered grid and so we
were using a we're using actually two
different meshes to simulate the system
two different mess well on a single mesh
you would end up having four corners
four edges and centers so you'd get nine
different types of objects in one
electrode alone and we're talking about
a rather large and nasty simulation on a
small scale the simulation would produce
a very sparse matrix that looks
something like this
and Sudarshan will mount come up and
talk to you about the matrices
so basically like John said lies the
most computation expensive part of the
small simulation this is the solving for
the Newton retread at Newton as
iterations during each door step and and
so basically an abstract any questions
sorry I'll try but you've gotta try and
listen harder equations and for
simplicity for the first pass the Gauss
elimination treating assuming that
ignoring all the the zeros of the matrix
and so the basic idea is that you you do
the full we do consultation with partial
pivoting and
it's the forward elimination stage of
the Gauss elimination that's that's
order n cube there's most expensive and
that's the thing that you've tried to
paralyze between among these views but
the partial pivoting and the partial so
this is the matrix that that we are
considering at during each stock filled
with random entries and filled with
random right-hand side the way Gauss
elimination works is that is the way we
start off with with one of the rows
which you call the base row which is we
take all and then we we illuminate the
variable corresponding to base row from
all the subsequent
be done in peril and that's what we have
tried to paralyze so each SPU grabs all
grab sort of the next available
elimination drop eliminates it and
writes the result back on down to the
main memory what we what we do is that
we stream the rows across each SPU
performs the illumination as you can see
it if this happens for every row so once
the so I in this simulation the first
wearable has been eliminated as you can
see there are zeros along the first
column and in the end that the process
is recursive after after the first
variable is completed it moves on to the
next so that's basically how and and as
you can and the way the the illumination
rows are dealt out are there data in a
cyclic fashion so there is no serial I'm
sorry yes the matrix representation
currently stands yes so so so so then
elimination synchronization step where
all the views have to synchronize there
is a very enough to each yeah so you say
started so so there's a triply nested
for loop if the right
and the first turn and then if it's the
inner two loops that are paralyzed and
that's the second move is what we try to
badness so this is the this is the basic
algorithm and let John talk about some
of the performance numbers we've got but
but some of the optimizations that we
have tried that we haven't done our user
last three operations by string
computation at the current elimination
row with the fetching of the next
elimination row we can roughly a 30
percent speed on so here's a graph look
to see how both the umpire and a buffer
version performed alone with a number of
skeletons another best to use so as you
can see both of the roughly pretty
linear and that makes sense because and
so so here's here's another graph of how
we how we stand the size of the matrix
that we're working with so the smaller
the matrix the higher the communication
computation ratio so the communication
latency should be more acquired but as
you can see even even as you get smaller
computations is still pretty linear
yeah yeah so I'll talk about some of the
further work we're trying to do so we've
also tried to triple buffer by
pipelining the fetching of the of the
next row with the computation of the
current row with the sending of the
previous row we did this but it didn't
actually give us the speed-up that we
thought we would get guising the
computation stage so right now we treat
the rows as all the doubles in the rows
of scalars that we could use the are
symbolizing hopefully we can get a
speed-up of by a factor of two and also
right now our Lu algorithm isn't very
smart in that when we fetch the
elimination row as we go on through the
algorithm part of the elimination row
becomes zeroes as we move down so
we don't really need to fetch the entire
lumination row and so by taking that
into account our memory the transfer our
DMA transfers are smaller this is the
Lanier's now
to examine Lily's leadership papers by
technical guards weren't aiming that W
to do regulations they did they use
single precision to get an approximate
yes and then did the two iterations of
any good at it
yeah
the hope is to generalize this to the
sparse matrices their time and and not I
don't think that the I think they are
trying to do some work with sparse
matrices but they all got one additional
question and just at a high level is
this the right way to tackle this
particular problem and it strikes me
that there must be a closed-form high
level macroscopic model for battery self
discharge I don't know anything about
the chemistry of lit acid batteries but
here a little write-up on the website
mentions black Scholes which I do know
something about and of course there are
efficient ways of doing that so solving
this system of equations is in the
literature if you were going to if you
were going to choose this as your model
but well building building and well see
the battery but not wouldn't he try and
come up with a you well it depends on
what your compute costs are I mean if
you know if you are going to run a model
on a superscalar processor that's a very
expensive processor if however now you
have the ability to use a collection of
small cheap you know little processors
like this you can maybe have the luxury
of using a much more sophisticated model
so they're necessarily more
sophisticated mean is there some
fundamental reason why you get more
information out of this approach than
higher level uh you get a lot more
detail as to what's going on within your
battery a high level model will give you
I owe information but if you're trying
to find failure mechanisms you may want
to know how much pressure is going on at
certain points your battery especially
with like lithium-ion batteries when
you're into this is this difference from
a lithium-ion battery in that we're
actually changing the state the type of
matter that we're using and in
lithium-ion battery we're intercalating
in the intercalating and so what we're
doing is we're creating a lot of stress
on a matrix my crystal and that will be
a failure mechanism a simple input
output relationship will
give you that failure mechanism so you
may want to know that kind of
information you may want to know heat
information also you could include you
know thermo dynamical information this
kind of model okay that's a good answer
I take that to mean that the reason for
doing this is if you're researching the
know physics of battery discharge as
opposed to trying to estimate how much
well you could you could use it if you
have the computation power you could use
the same model that does the research as
is the car and so yeah if you can use
small process our demonstration if you
guys want to see print def statements
just the main you scan that sparse
versus dentists you think I just do a
sparse elimination I'm on you know
processor you get a bigger speed oh you
get a much bigger speed okay you know
the sparse is the Lu is about yeah
slowest thing you could possibly choose
but if it works the way I got would
still be usable for dense matrices it'd
still be useful her to dance major did
you compare it on to just keep you
performance on a dense matrix uh no we
didn't compare it to PP you we we had a
compare we have the same model I'm
running on a PC